what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm waren Thompson
and it's been a while but for a very
long time in the MCU fandom you could
not stop hearing the word Mesto and it
looks like we could be entering a time
where that could possibly be happening
again however this time it's a little
bit different because this time it is
seemingly confirmed by a major outlet
and it looks like Marvel Studios
themselves could have possibly just
confirmed Mesto is indeed making his way
to the MCU in Phase 5 now a lot of
Industry insiders that we talk about on
this channel do have really good
credentials and track records which is
why we report what they State sometimes
and a few have talked about maista
coming back however the original report
that mafesto was going to be in the Iron
Heart series came from deadline a huge
outlet that has many different sources
over at Marvel Studios they reported
about a year ago October 18th of 2022
that they heard from sources at Marvel
that Sasha baric Cohen Borat himself was
likely playing mafesto in the Iron Heart
Series this is what their article said
speculation is growing that Sasha baric
Cohen has entered the Marvel Cinematic
Universe with a role in Marvel studios's
upcoming Disney plus series iron Hart as
a comic book villain a source close to
the production confirmed to deadline
that there is talk on the set about
Cohen being part of Iron Heart likely
playing Mesto he has also been spotted
at the Marvel facilities located at UK's
Pinewood Studios and since then we have
had some insiders state that Sasha baric
Cohen is playing mafesto and we actually
have learned quite a bit of information
about Mesto in the MCU thanks to these
insiders and one thing that we have
learned about misto in the MCU is that
if this all really does happen he's not
just going to be a oneandone but he is
going to be sort of a main character of
the MCU moving forward and is not just
going to be in one project project but
most likely multiple projects and today
it seems like Marvel Studios might have
confirmed that Sasha bar Cohen is indeed
going to be playing Mesto now recently
you might have heard that Marvel Studios
has recently filed with the US copyright
office they filed for many different
shows including Agatha darkhold Diaries
Daredevil born again and iron heart and
here are some awesome news they have
confirmed Sasha bar Cohen is indeed
going to be an iron heart with this us
copyright filing so this is Marvel
Studios themselves they have just
confirmed Sasha baric Cohen is indeed in
the film that's not coming from anybody
else but directly from Marvel this is on
the official public records copyright
site the government site and it was
filed by Marvel it's official he's going
to be in the show but what's funny is
what they listed his character as they
gave us a whole plot synopsis for the
first episode as well here's what it
says description of the work Marvel
Studios presents Iron Heart in which
Charming teenage Super Genius IUS Riri
Williams played by Dominique Thorne
returns from MIT to her hometown of
Chicago in her iron suit and begins to
unravel threads that bring danger and
Adventure right to her doorstep the
adventure begins in episode 101 as Riri
is introduced to the audience and for
episode 101 it pretty much stops there
but then it starts to say the main cast
includes Dominique Thorne as Riri
Williams Anthony Ramos as Parker Robbins
who of course is the hood and is going
to be the main antagonist of the show it
goes on to list a lot more people and it
tells us exactly who their characters
are except when it comes to Sasha baren
it simply States Sasha Barak Cohen as
mystery man they don't actually tell us
who he is playing and there are a few
different reasons for this especially
based off of some things that we've
heard from some insiders one is I think
Marvel just really doesn't want to sit
there and confirm themselves before the
show comes out before a big reveal comes
out that Sasha baric Cohen is misto they
love to let us come up with theories
they love for the rumors and reports to
go crazy but they love to not confirm
anything until it's actually time but
we've gotten reports from some insiders
that tell us really what Marvel
studios's plans are for Mesto and the
MCU and it sounds like they are really
big we'll talk about those in just a bit
but first big thank you to fume for
sponsoring this
video fume is a game Cher for a lot of
people in turning back bad habits into
good habits a lot of people struggle
with these bad habits but fume looks at
these in a different way not everything
in the habit is wrong so instead of a
drastic uncomfortable change why not
just remove the bad from your habit and
that's exactly what fume does they're
Innovative and they're award-winning and
they're a flavored air device that's all
it is it's flavored air so it has none
of the bad things and the bad habit in
it instead of vapor it uses flavored Air
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors I had actually heard really
great things about fume from my friends
who were struggling with some bad habits
they actually raved about it and how it
helped them which is why I agreed to
partner with them and they sent me some
samples and they honestly are super
refreshing and taste very flavorful and
good and it comes in beautiful real wood
and it's honestly really fun to just sit
there and kind of fidget with if you're
someone who likes to fidget like I do
and I know stopping is something we all
put off because it's hard but with fume
it's easy and they have served over
150,000 customers and have thousands of
success stories and that could be you if
you pick up a journey pack today head
over to trf nume.com and use code Cosmic
to save 10% off when you get the journey
pack today that's
trfu m.com and use code Cosmic to save
an additional 10% off your order
today so despite Marvel Studios not
wanting to let the world know Mesto is
actually coming hey you've talked about
it for a long time it's pretty much been
a Meme here it is from what we've heard
the real reason they have listed him as
mystery man is simply because he might
not actually be revealed until the very
end of the series to be misto and even
then they might not actually call him
misto essentially it's kind of going to
be like in Loki season 1 in the finale
when they first meet he who remains and
he says that he's been called many names
a conqueror a jerk he who remains means
it's essentially going to be the same
for Mesto he's probably been called many
names like the devil the demon and Mesto
which is probably just going to be one
of the names that he has been given but
as far as why he is in the Iron Heart
Series this is what we know it sounds
like they're going to be changing the
origin story for the hood only a little
bit here in the comics the hood or
parker Robbins has a very very sick
mother who needs medical treatment and
he drops out of high school in order to
start stealing things so he could get
some money to help her one time him and
a buddy broke into a warehouse that was
said to have some valuable material and
they were attacked by a demon in a cloak
Parker Robin shot the demon and assumed
that he killed it but he didn't want to
leave empty-handed so he took its cloak
and he took its boots later on he would
go on to find out that the boots gave
him the ability to walk on air and the
cloak gave him Powers as well but he did
not know that the cloak originated from
the demon doramu now that's the comic
origin and in the show iron heart we
actually have heard that Mesto is going
to be the one responsible for giving the
powers or the cloak and the boots to
Parker Robbins and from what we've heard
about the show it's going to be a battle
between mystical magic and Technology
the technology obviously being the Iron
Heart suit that Riri Williams has and
the magic stemming at the core from
Mesto other reports from insiders have
also indicated that Mesto wants Iron Man
technology and that sometimes when we
see Mesto he is going to appear as a
very professional businessman The
Insider can we get get some toast
tweeted the hood is stealing tech for
mafesto in Iron Heart the question is
why then The Insider my time to shine
hello added Mesto in his human form owns
a tech company then the cosmic
circus.com reported this they stated our
sources can exclusively confirm that
mafesto was in fact the mysterious
benefactor that purchased Avengers Tower
from Tony Stark and Spider-Man
homecoming as of right now we can't
confirm if Tony Stark knew who he was
making a deal with or if he did why he
made a deal with someone like Mesto they
also stated although M festo's reason
for wanting Avengers Tower lines up with
what we already knew about iron heart
and that is the narrative that Kevin
has luded to being Magic versus
technology in iron heart so many
insiders very reliable insiders have
reported that Sasha baroan is indeed
going to be playing Mesto Mesto is going
to be playing a role in The Iron Heart
series and further on in the MCU and
deadline reported a year ago that Sasha
baric Cohen was going to be making his
MCU debut in iron heart as Maisto and
after all of those reports it seems like
Marvel Studios basically confirmed to us
Sasha baric Cohen is indeed Mesto by
listing him on this us copyright filing
as mystery man it seems like the reveal
of mafesto is going to be slowly and
gradually revealed but no doubt he'll
play a huge role in the MCU moving
forward and we're going to get our first
taste of him in the Iron Heart Series so
go ahead and let us know what you think
about this news in the comments down
below Mesto is finally coming after all
this time after all the jokes after all
the memes he's finally here well soon
enough at least so let us know what you
think about this in the comments down
below don't forget to like this video
And subscribe so you don't miss out on
anything relating to the mzu also if you
subscribe and leave a comment on our
videos you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win a PS5
an Xbox series X some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items the winner picks
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof